if we're gonna keep it a buck and I know
we all feel this way if there we go I've
never sucked a dick before but like I'll
be good at it you gotta be passionate
about it to be good at it though oh so
yeah would you perform it describe it
unbarked man that's hard damn you're
hard already what was the question again
describe how you would do it
enthusiasm dude we both can't like the
same thing I'm talking about the
technique did you take the balls yeah I
think you have to reach for the balls a
little bit
okay You Gotta Be handsy You got to be
touching up here a little bit dude I'm
gonna be touched on my [__] tits
that's what you that's what I like
that's what he likes yeah we can't argue
like your breasts cup while you're
getting blowjobed a little bit
sometimes hands on the cheeks you don't
like hands of the cheeks like this yeah
push it in the butt cheeks of course not
the face cheeks
it wouldn't be this it'd be [__] down